les tests de dépistage sont parmi les
éléments les plus importants de la lutte
contre la copie de 19 il permet de
découvrir le nombre de cas dans un pays
c'est la propagation s'accélère au
ralenti et même de découvrir des
nouveaux variants mais tous ces tests ne
sont pas parfaits chacun a ses avantages
et ses inconvénients et savoir lequel
utilisé dans quel contexte est crucial
pour bien comprendre l'évolution de la
pandémie
comment fonctionnent les tests de
dépistage
le plus utilisé c'est le test par pcr
cette technique utilise une machine qui
peut détecter la présence de matériel
génétique spécifique au virus sras
skovde 2 dans les très petits
échantillons qui viennent du nez de la
gorge ou parfois de la salive des
personnes qui seront testés puisque la
quantité de matériel génétique viral
dans ses échantillons et un film et
qu'elle baigne au milieu de matériel
génétique humain le test par pcr
utilisent des molécules qui à chaque
cycle de la machine vont copier le
matériel génétique du virus à chaque
cycle on double la quantité de matériel
génétique viral après aussi on a grandi
s'est progressivement une image jusqu'à
ce qu'on puisse dire si oui ou non la
personne est infectée
le test par pressèrent al'avantage
d'être très précis mais il est seulement
capable de nous dire si une personne est
infectée ou non pas de nous dire quel
est le stade de la maladie ou si la
personne est encore contagieuse le test
par pcr aussi le défaut de prendre
plusieurs heures avant de fournir un
résultat parfois même des jours s'il
faut qu on ajouta seul transport des
échantillons et c'est aussi un test qui
coûte beaucoup d'argent
est ce que ces tests peuvent donner des
résultats erronés
même avec des tests aussi sensible que
la pch
il arrive qu'on est ce qu'on appelle des
faux positifs ces erreurs surviennent
lorsque les échantillons sont exposés du
matériel génétique contaminants ou qu'on
laisse la réaction d'amplification duré
trop longtemps
c'est pour ça que tous les laboratoires
à travers le monde ont des mesures pour
minimiser ces risques par exemple chaque
test est accompagné d'un échantillon
négatif qui sert de contrôle
si le contrôle négatif donne un résultat
positif
on sait que quelque chose n'a pas
fonctionné avec le test et on recommence
en plus des études de suivi au canada où
un peu partout à travers le monde ont
montré qu'entre 70 et 80% des résultats
positifs à la kfw 19 ont été obtenus
lors de tests qui ont duré entre 12 et
25 cycle on est donc très loin des
plafonds de 40 cycle à partir desquels
les faux positifs commencent parfois
apparaître
pour toutes ces raisons la plupart des
laboratoires considère qu'en ce qui
concerne les tests de coved 19 les faux
positifs sont très rares quels sont les
autres tests pour dépister la coved 19
pour une détection plus rapide que les
tests par pcr
on peut utiliser des tests antigénique
qui vont détecter directement la
présence de fragments du virus dans un
échantillon de patients
un peu comme un test de grossesse on
dépose ses échantillons sur une bande
l'être dans un contenant et au bout de
quelques minutes le test nous indique si
le virus est présent ou non
mais puisqu'il n'y a aucune étape
d'amplification dans ce test
il faut beaucoup de virus pour pouvoir
déterminer si la personne est infectée
ou non ce test permet donc de
reconnaître les personnes qui transporte
beaucoup de virus mais peuvent rater des
personnes en début ou en fin de maladies
qui sont quand même contagieuse c'est
pour ces raisons que ces tests raté deux
doivent quand même être confirmée plus
tard par pcr
il existe aussi un troisième type de
test où on va mesurer le taux
d'anticorps dans le saint des personnes
ces tests permettent de savoir si
quelqu'un déjà eu la kfw 19 par le passé
mais ne permettent pas de reconnaître si
quelqu'un est infecté présentement
comment procède-t-on à la surveillance
des variantes
si on veut identifier un invariant il
faut séquencé le génome du virus
le séquençage permet de dresser une
liste de tous les jeunes et de toutes
les mutations qu'on trouve dans un
échantillon c'est ce qui nous permet de
savoir s'ils ont affaire invariants
d'intérêt qu'on connaît déjà
ou même de découvrir des nouveaux
variants les combinaisons mutation qu'on
n'avait pas encore vu jusqu'à maintenant
au canada la plupart des provinces et
ces deux séquences et jusqu'à 10% de
tous les échantillons positifs à la
coved 19 mai obtenir les résultats d'un
test séquençage prend du temps jusqu'à
une semaine
c'est aussi un test qui nécessite du
matériel spécialisé
si donc pas l'idéal pour faire de la
surveillance à grande échelle de la
progression des variants dans un pays
pour accélérer les choses
on utilise donc maintenant le criblage
génétique le criblage permet de chercher
les mutations précise déjà associé à des
variants dans des échantillons
ça nous permet de faire le suivi de la
progression des variants à l'échelle
d'un pays
mais ces tests sont pas assez précis
pour être capables de nous permettre de
savoir exactement à quel type de vario
on a affaire ils nous permettent pas non
plus de découvrir des nouveaux variants
qu'on connaissait pas déjà c'est pour
cette raison que criblage et séquençage
sont deux tests complémentaires
on comprend donc que si on veut
comprendre ce qui se passe à l'échelle
d'un pays
il faut utiliser tous les outils dont on
a parlé jusqu'à maintenant que ce soit
les tests de détection ou les tests de
séquençage génétique
c'est uniquement en combinant toutes ces
données qu'on va être en mesure de mieux
comprendre qu'est ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et de prendre des décisions
éclairées pour mettre fin à la pandémie
si vous avez d'autres questions
n'hésitez pas à nous les faire parvenir
à l'adresse que vous voyez à l'écran et
nous on va y répondre le plus rapidement
possible